I've seen you do Janice Joplin and you
do you do her better than anybody and
that's those are tough songs to sing
what happened with that project where
everyone was saying pink is gonna play
yeah you know I think it's uh I think
honestly Janice doesn't want it made
I think there's a lot of things that go
into that I think it's a lot harder to
get a a biopic done about a female
that's why we don't have that many
and also
um
I just don't think Janice wants it made
there was some Linda Perry was once
slated to play Janice Brittany Murphy
there's been so many people
I mean there's had to have been at least
10 10 projects that didn't fly and uh to
me that's like that's a bigger Janice
wasn't also they want to make it a happy
ending
it's not a happy ending I mean it's a
it's a completion but it's it's not the
truth nobody wants what do you mean well
you saw an actual script that said yeah
and they want it to be that Janice chose
to to just end it in a no dude she
overdosed and also I wasn't there I
can't say the whole story but it
certainly wasn't a happy ending no she
wasn't even Pearl didn't even take off
until after she died you wanted that
role of Janis Joplin and I personally
I'm not Mr Hollywood but I certainly
know of three women that I know
personally who were supposed to play
Janice Joplin yeah
and you're right it just never and it
would have been I'm sure a remarkable
movie
you think that's what it is you think
Hollywood doesn't want to make a Janice
Joplin movie because she's a woman I
think it's part of it